[Music]
chris john congratulations you guys have
made it into the third round of this
competition now we're sending you back
to your home forges to recreate this
iconic weapon from american history
general patton saber
[Music]
good luck we'll see you in four days
[Music]
today i'm gonna build the actual blade
part of the saber i'm making a ladder
pattern damascus billet i'm stacking
1085 and
15 and 20. so ladder pattern damask it's
a simple pattern i'm going to weld it
put some layers into it and then cut it
with the chop saw and then draw it out
[Music]
this is a large blade and there can be a
lot of things that go wrong with this
much forging so i'm not comfortable
putting all my eggs just in that one
billet so my plan is to make a 5160
dollar so i have insurance that i'll
have a good blade for this build i got
lots of eggs i got tons of eggs and you
guys need some eggs anybody want eggs
today i hope to get the blade quenched
so i need to get this fire going
i picked up a little bit of a curve in
this thing
i do notice that it's not an exact even
heat up in the fire there's more heat
towards either end than in the middle i
don't want to waste too much more time
chasing it out there's always a chance a
lot of it'll come back out once i dip it
in the quench
i believe my blade has gotten hot enough
i am ready to quench
well my blade was heating up it wasn't
an exact even heat up in the fire so i
do still have a fairly significant
s-curve warp to it so i quickly throw it
between a couple of big chunks of wood
to see if i can address the work
if this doesn't work i'm screwed
okay
i've got a very very slight warble right
towards the end but i'm positive i could
take it out with the grinder so we might
be in good shape
[Music]
i feel pretty good about that
i think i'm getting very slightly soft
close to the hilt rather than go through
the quench process again i think i'm
just going to go with it keep my fingers
crossed and pray to the gods
this morning i'll figure out which blade
is going to be worthy of going forward i
really want the damascus to be my sword
so i start grinding on it
and right away i start seeing some
delaminations and this edge here
they want to fall apart
i'm going to scrap the damascus save it
for the back strap and move on to the
5160 and make that my blade i'm not
going to take a risk with 10 000 on the
line
i go to the forge get it hot and i go on
the quick stink
when i pull this knife out of the oil i
have a nice straight sword
it's the morning of day four i think
i've got myself set up really well for a
final day of construction and refinement
once i have my wood block shaped for my
handle i start figuring out how i'm
going to try to make this back strap got
this old kind of cool looking spoon of
unknown metal i think it's some sort of
steel plated in some sort of other metal
but it looks cool and i'm going to beat
and bash and bend it until it fits
around the back of my hand
all right i get it glued up to the rest
of the sword now once my epoxy sets it's
going to be time to moving on to
sharpening
this blade is as sharp as a razor
and it's ready for testing
each wheel cut
today i got to put everything together
put the final edge on the sword and test
it
so it's time to get the guard started
so go up to the plasma cutter and we cut
out a piece of sheet metal that's going
to become our guard i'm a horseshoer we
have horses put a horse on it or said
for the cowboy sword this is my version
of the cowboys cavalry sword
say that twice
i'm going to acid edge to guard black
and i'm going to put some enamel over
the top just to preserve it and then
find the inside of the guard with pig
leather so make sure it's nice and comfy
for their hands i finished assembling
the sword just with enough daylight to
be able to test it
this is whiskey
hey work
i'm finished building this crazy sword
and why not go out with a
bang america
welcome to the kill test your sabres
look deadly
to find it out i will take your weapon
deliver some slashes and thrusts on this
ballistic stump
john you're first you ready for this
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
cut its heart out
it's just not
right all right john first up let's talk
about the handle construction it's a
little bit on the big side but i'm able
to hold on to it now
your edge
it's very sharp
and it is a pleasure to wield because
aside from looking beautiful
it will kill
thank you very much
all right chris your turn are you ready
sir yes sir i sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right chris let's talk about your
saber here
first up what i love about it it's got a
sharp edge every swing i do cuts the one
thing here is that you did pick up a
little bit of a bend right here at this
junction it's warped a little bit
but it pierces and cuts
and most importantly
it will kill
thank you sir
all right blade smiths for a strength
test i'm going to take your sabers
and i'm going to beat them and stab them
into these field obstacles
now i'm not really concerned about what
your swords do to our obstacles i want
to see the opposite what they do to your
swords john you're first you ready to go
ready to go
ah
[Music]
nice job john i like the blade
the sword itself overall is on the heavy
side the handle is a lot there a lot of
extra weight it does help counterbalance
quite a bit though
still got a good edge on it there's some
pretty heavy strikes on there and the
blade bent but came back to true it's
all right tight and straight
good job thank you hey feeling chris
good as i can be sir all right
lucky day
chris your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure in our strength
test and unfortunately
you cannot continue with testing which
means you cannot be the foreign fire
champion
please exit the forge come on forward
pal
i did have a small issue when it got to
my heat treat
that's right i didn't want to risk a
second quench because i didn't want to
make it overly brittle i do have some
regret about that decision at this point
of course i would like to be the fortune
fire champion but i am really proud of
myself as a weapons maker and i plan on
getting right back in my forge when i
get home and i'm gonna move forward as
ever
well john general patton was known for
being a tough guy and you made a tough
and sharp sword that really honors his
name congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job
thank you thank you
how do you feel right now oh yeah
all right man come on over and shake our
hands
good job brother it's a beautiful sword
yeah
i'm the new forage and fire champion did
a phenomenal job in that hatred thank
you sir i'm proud of what i did and it's
been a fun deal hey can i get a forge
and fire bub buckle now
no bell buckle come on
[Music]
you